we're on problem 226
in the figure above let me draw the
figure above
so
i have a line there and then i have
another line it goes like that and then
this is a triangle like that
and then they draw another line that
goes straight down like that
and they call this right here z degrees
this is y degrees this is x degrees they
tell us that these are right angles
fair enough in the figure above if z is
equal to 50 so that is equal to 50
degrees then x plus y is equal to what
well if z is 50 well first of all we
know since these are both right angles
these both both of these lines
are going to be parallel
right both of those lines are parallel
and so you could view
you could view this green line as a
transversal of the parallel
and so
z and y are corresponding angles so y is
also going to be 50 and that should make
a little intuitive sense but you could
watch the khan academy geometry videos
if that doesn't make sense but just
eyeballing it looks right too but that's
a property of transversals and parallel
lines
and if that's true then what is this
angle right here well 50 plus 90 plus
this angle
is equal to
180
right
but so we could say 50
plus 90 plus theta is equal to 180.
so you get 140
plus theta
is equal to 180. subtract 140 from both
sides theta is equal to 40.
so theta is equal to 40 degrees so if
this angle right here is 40 degrees
what's x
well there's supplementary they have to
add up they have to add up to be
180 right this whole angle is 180. so
that whole angle is 180 this is 40 then
this then x has to be 140 degrees
so they wanted to know what x plus y is
well x is 140 y is 50. so 140 plus 50 is
190 degrees
and that is not one of the choices so i
must have oh i see i see my mistake
this angle right here actually we're
still completely fine this angle right
here isn't y
this angle right here is y but
everything we did so far still holds if
this angle is 50 this angle is still 50
since it's a corresponding angle right
and if that's 50 this is 90 then this is
40.
x is 140. now we just have to figure out
y is
well y is supplementary with this angle
right here
right
so y
plus this angle that i used to think was
y
until i looked closely at the drawing
y plus 50 has to be equal to 180 degrees
right because it's complementary with
this 50 degree angle
so y
is equal to 130
so x plus y is equal to
140
plus 130
which is equal to 270 degrees and that's
choice d
problem 227
looks like they've drawn another
coordinate axis which i'll draw
nope that's not what i wanted to draw
with
and draw with that
okay and then they
they have a line that comes down
something like
that
and they mark it off
they say that this is
let me see how they mark it off they say
this is the point
one
this is the point one this is a point
two they don't write the two there they
call this line l this is the origin
this is the x-axis and that is the
y-axis and they say in the coordinate
system above which of the following
is the equation
of line l is the equation well if we
just i bought i mean they don't say it
explicitly but it looks like this is
intersecting at y is equal to two and
this is intersecting at y is equal to
three
i guess that's a safe assumption
so how do we set up this equation well
you just have to figure out the slope
and the y-intercept we already know the
y-intercept right it intersects
when y when x is 0 so y of 0 when x is 0
y is equal to 2. so that's the
y-intercept and now we just have to
figure out the slope
well let's think about the slope if we
take this point
if we take
well there's i'll do it the formal way
right the slope is equal to
change in y over change in x
so let's take this as the endpoint this
is three comma zero
and let's see who's on the phone
if it's someone oh
i'll take that call i'll continue this
in the next video